here the Deputy Prime Minister says he's
delighted that the Lib Dems have
persuaded the government to bring in
rules forcing businesses to publish how
much they pay men and women doing the
same job well let's talk about this now
with Harini
younger he's a barrister specializing in
discrimination and employment law as she
joins us now from a central London very
good afternoon to you what difference do
you think this change in the law would
make good afternoon to my mind it's a
very significant development we've had
the Equal Pay ruled on the statute books
since 1970 and it's also no surprise to
businesses and workers that we've got a
pay gap problem in the country the
improvement in the gap between men and
women's pay has been really slow you
might say glacial and we've also had
this provision section 78 of the
Equality Act 2010 on the statute books
for five years but no one has brought it
into force in the autumn we saw a
campaign to by Sarah champion and Grazia
magazine and then we were under the
impression that it was going to go idle
because of the election so it's quite a
surprise to hear it's going to be
brought into force I think there'll be
two major impacts first of all it makes
a shift from it being a problem for
individual women to sue their own
employer off their own bat get hold of
the evidence by hook or by crook
lots of skirmish is about disclosure and
it changes it into a regulatory issue
for businesses so I think that's going
to herald a huge cultural shift from a
sort of sideline feminist issue to a
mainstream risk issue for businesses a
regulatory risk issue and the second
change speaking as someone who's
litigated a lot of equal pay claims
representing employers as well as
employees I think he's going to change
the tactics it's always been difficult
to know as an employer how much you
should disclose about colleagues pay to
individual women how much is going to be
relevant what about the confidentiality
of the colleagues and similarly if
you're a litigant you know what should
you be asking for are you going to get
it when you're going to get it and how
does that affect how you bring your
claim I think there's going to be a huge
shift now because the principle will be
that bigger businesses should be
transparent about pay
and give us an idea of just how wide the
pay gap is at the moment how big a
problem do we have because the
government says it's at its lowest level
ever they maintain it's been virtually
eliminated for those people working
full-time under the age of 40 s what's
your take well that there are statistics
and statistics here if you look at just
full-time pay without including overtime
it's now at the lowest level it's true
it's about nine point four percent but
in this country we have a lot of
segregation between men and women in the
labor market and we have horizontal
segregation which is certain occupations
like child care say or teaching very
female dominated occupations like heavy
industry or banking very male-dominated
and then we also have vertical
stratification which means you look at a
profession like teaching a lot of women
in the junior positions very few women
at the top and that same vertical
stratification you see in professions
like the law and if you look at what the
ONS office for national statistics calls
the higher skills and trades more
skilled profession the pay gap is now 25
percent and when you look at the
financial services sector it's as high
as 55 percent well there's also a
difference between the public sector and
the private sector the public sector pay
gap now is I believe around 11% and the
average private sector pay gap is around
17% okay well hurry knee younger really
interesting to talk to you thanks very
much indeed thank you